En el momento de su independencia del
Imperio Británico en 1963, y tras haber
sido su economía, además, devastada por
la ocupación japonesa durante la
segunda guerra mundial, Singapur no era
más que una aglomeración de chabolas
donde cocinas y baños tenían que ser
compartidas por varias familias. En un
primer momento Singapur se unió a Malasia, pero apenas dos años después en
1965 y tras diversos enfrentamientos
políticos y étnicos con el
aristócrata y extractivos gobierno de
Malasia, Singapur fue expulsado de la
Federación malaya y obligada de facto a
declararse independiente.
En ese momento el desafío que se le
presentaba a este pequeño territorio era
enorme:
Singapur era un lugar pobre, tenía menos
de dos millones de habitantes y
carecía de todo recurso natural.
¡Ni siquiera era un territorio autosuficiente
respecto a la alimentación y al agua!
Sin embargo, pese a todo, apenas cinco
décadas después
Singapur es una de las capitales del
mundo y uno de los territorios más ricos.
Atentos de hecho al siguiente gráfico
que refleja su impresionante éxito
económico y la diferencia con muchos de
nuestros países
Y es que, desde 1960 la economía de
Singapur ha crecido más del 7,5 por
ciento cada año convirtiéndose, así, en
el proceso de desarrollo más rápido de
toda la historia.
Hoy la renta per cápita de esta ciudad
estado es muy superior a la de Estados
Unidos, más que duplica la de España y
casi multiplica por cuatro la de Chile
que es el líder latinoamericano.
Sencillamente es impresionante.
Bien, Lee Kun Yew, el primer ministro de Singapur
entre 1959 y 1990, y, además, considerado el
artífice de este milagro económico,
coqueteó en un primer momento con las
llamadas políticas ISI, esto es, de
industrialización por sustitución de
importaciones, que mediante el
proteccionismo tratan de impulsar el
desarrollo, y que han sido muy populares
en América Latina durante todo el siglo XX.
Y de hecho en cierto modo aún lo
siguen siendo, por ejemplo, en países
como Ecuador. - "Las autoridades económicas
del país confirmaron que 2.800
subpartidas o líneas de productos que
ingresan al país estarán gravadas con
aranceles o sobre tasas". Sin embargo,
pronto se dio cuenta de que este tipo de
iniciativas no resultaban el mejor
camino para desarrollar un país sumido
en la pobreza. Por eso a partir de 1965
se puso en marcha el enfoque de éxito
que transformó Singapur: la apertura al
mercado global.
Ahora bien ¡ojo! porque Singapur no
ha sido ni mucho menos un prototipo de
estado libertario ortodoxo, donde
el gobierno no se entromete en la actividad
económica. Al contrario, el gobierno de
Singapur ha jugado un papel muy
destacado y en muchas casos de claro liderazgo.
Pero antes de que os lancéis encima
mío, es verdad, con un enfoque muy
diferente de lo que estamos
acostumbrados.
- "Las cosas están cambiando rápido y
estamos teniendo que ajustarnos y seguir
el ritmo; debido a la tecnología, a la
globalización, tenemos que anticipar que
está sucediendo,
tenemos que ayudar a las empresas y
trabajadores a adaptarse". En Singapur el
gobierno no jugó a ocupar parcelas cada
vez mayores de la economía, ni a regular
todos en cada uno de los espacios hasta
el mínimo detalle ni a expandir por
supuesto el gasto público y los
impuestos,
todo lo contrario, en el caso de Singapur
prácticamente podemos hablar de la
adquisición por parte de los poderes
público de una noción de estado-empresa
o, mejor dicho en este caso, de
ciudad-empresa. -"La compañía
es de ustedes, de ustedes los accionistas".
Es decir, Lee Kuan Yew entendió que
Singapur necesitaba atraer capitales y
profesionales para poder crecer y
desarrollarse y que precisamente en un
marco de competencia imperfecta entre
economías y países muy intervenidos, el
estado podría jugar un papel clave.
Eso sí, con políticas que favoreciesen la
competitividad, la inversión y la
atracción de empresas y no la
burocracia en el asistencialismo.
- "Me encanta que los planes salgan bien".
Así, por ejemplo, las autoridades
singapurenses desarrollaron
instituciones que tenían como fin
garantizar la seguridad jurídica y una
gestión eficiente de la ciudad,
promovieran sectores económicos
determinados mediante la colaboración
público-privada, trazaron un ambicioso
programa de infraestructuras productivas e impulsaron el ahorro.
Eso sí, todas las políticas se
diseñaron en un marco de estricta
estabilidad presupuestaria y siempre
pensando en su integración con los
agentes privados, algo que rara vez
ocurre por ejemplo en España. -"Pero señor
alcalde, es que una costa es una costa. - ¿Y qué, pues se hace? - pero ¿cómo traemos el mar? - ¿no
han puesto una playa en Madrid?". Es decir,
no se trata tanto de ampliar un puerto
como de integrar un marco jurídico
institucional atractivo con servicio que
conduzcan a las empresas a instalarse en
un país, en este caso Singapur, y a que
crecer en productividad.
Insisto, la diferencia es muy
importante prácticamente podemos decir
que el estado de Singapur es un
proveedor de servicio con vocación
competitiva. En Singapur
el gobierno entendió que la propia
comunidad, la ciudad institucional, era un activo
y que bien gestionada podía convertirse
en toda una ventaja competitiva.
Podemos poner como ejemplo dos
políticas: 1º) lograr que la
ciudad a pesar de contar con una
altísima densidad de población, no
fuese un lugar caótico, ruidos y
contaminado. Para ello, ya en 1975
pusieron tasas a la congestión y hoy el
tráfico está sometido a peajes que se
cobran electrónicamente a todos los
usuarios de la vía, a  todo los vehículos.
Es decir, de esta forma se imputaron los
costes de mantenimiento de las calles, de
las carretera,s a los usuarios reales de
las mismas, al tiempo que lograban evitar
los atascos y gran parte de la
contaminación,
- "Mira cómo ha encandilado a ese Subaru".
El resultado es que hoy Singapur tiene
un tráfico muy fluido y que éste se
distribuye conforme a lo que le genera a
cada usuario la utilización de la misma
carretera.
Por supuesto, al tiempo, Singapur
desarrolló una excelente, eficiente y
asequible sistema de transporte público.
Otra medida mucho más controvertida por su paternalismo, fue obligar a todos los
trabajadores a invertir un cuarto de
su salario en un rígido plan de ahorro
nacional que es gestionado, además, por
una organización estatal.
Con este programa el gobierno de la isla
persigue que los trabajadores conformen
un patrimonio con lo que poder sufragar
servicios sanitarios, servicios educativos
así como la propia jubilación. Y
mientras eso ocurre el estado obtiene
los recursos necesarios para invertir
dentro y fuera del país en proyectos
que se entiende sean esenciales para la
competitividad de la ciudad.
En cierto modo de esta forma los
trabajadores pasan a ser no sólo
usuarios sino también inversores en
esta ciudad-empresa.
Por supuesto este tipo de "intervenciones"
donde el estado mantiene un acosado
liderazgo, son complementadas con una
política decida en favor de la libre
empresa y una de las regulaciones más libres
del mundo en materia de circulación de
capitales, mercancías y trabajadores.
En Singapur los impuestos son reducidos,
por ejemplo una renta de 60 mil dólares
viene a pagar un 5 por ciento del
impuesto de la renta, los aranceles son
prácticamente inexistentes,
no hay salario mínimo, el gasto público
supone aproximadamente el 18% del PIB,
es la segunda economía más libre del
mundo y según el Banco Mundial es el
país donde más fácil resulta hacer
negocios
¡casi nada! - "Miren, en el mundo que vivimos
hoy, ser periférico o ser central no
depende de la ubicación física de tu
país, depende de si tienes o no una
habitación y una economía del
conocimiento.
Depende de la tecnología, es lo único
que puede explicar que países como
Singapur tengan mucha mejor educación
que nosotros". El resultado de todo ello
es que un país que hasta hace unas
pocas décadas era muy pobre hoy es uno de
los más ricos del mundo, cuenta con
varias universidades entre las mejores,
sus estudiantes están a la cabeza en
materias como ciencias y matemática, su
sistema sanitario es considerado
excelente,
no hay paro, no hay delincuencia y las
expectativas son extraordinarias.
Por ejemplo en el Índice de Desarrollo
Humano elaborado por Naciones Unidas,
ocupa la plaza once, por encima de
países como Suecia, Islandia, Francia
o Finlandia. De hecho, os puedo asegurar
que en pocos sitios he experimentado tanto
la movilidad social y las oportunidades
de crecimiento profesional como cuando
he estado en este pequeño estado que
hoy se ha convertido en toda una
potencia industrial comercial y
turística.
La cara negativa, que la tiene, se
concentra en el sistema político, que
aunque está evolucionando aun sigue
siendo muy restrictivo con las
libertades civiles.
En Singapur las penas de cárcel son
altísimas, la censura es normal y los
comportamientos diferentes no suelen ser bien considerados.
De todo esto y de más hablaremos en
futuras videos, porque, desde luego,
Singapur es uno de los países más
fascinantes de todo el mundo y un
auténtico imán para los profesionales
de todos los lugares.
Bueno, ¿a ti qué te parece? ¿Crees que
Singapur es un modelo a seguir?
¿Crees que el estado tiene que gestionar
el patrimonio público para lograr
extraer rendimientos como si de una
empresa se tratara? ¿Qué defectos le ves
a esta ciudad-empresa?
Espero que te haya gustado el video, si ha sido así dale a Like, y no te olvides
de estar atento a nuestras novedades en
facebook y en twitter. Un saludo y
hasta la próxima.